as another way of representing it the
dragon of chaos stands for the potential
that surrounds us inside of that there's
the unknown the unknown that you
actually come into contact with right
that's the unknown as it actually
manifests itself in your world as
something you don't understand instead
of just the potential for that because
we say look you know perfectly well that
as you're sitting here there's all sorts
of things you don't know everywhere but
where are they well they're not not
investing themselves at the moment
they're only in potential but you could
we could have a discussion that that
became argumentative and then all of a
sudden it would be as if emissaries of
that unknown had entered the space and
that's the unknown that's defined in
relationship to what you know that's
what you actually experience instead of
it only being potential it's a tough
thing to get because they're both
unknown right you think well how can
there be two different categories of
unknown
well latent and manifest that's a good
way of thinking about it though you in a
relationship it's going stabili but you
know that sooner or later something will
come up okay up from where Y up from
from beneath well what do you mean
beneath well it's from its from your
complex the person you're in
relationship with it in with it's
complicated and complex that's implicit
in you it's it's inside your conceptual
structure that's that's a way of looking
at it now and then when there's a
disagreement it will manifest itself and
you know that you know that there's
still trouble brewing ahead in a
relationship always and that's part of
what keeps them alive or is an
interesting piece of empirical work done
on this a while back so you might think
well what is the optimal relationship
look like in terms of positive a
negative emotion you might say well
utopia nothing but positive interactions
it's like no now Jen you get people to
code the interactions they have with
their partner during the day you know
you sample it you say with that
interaction positive or negative and
then what you're trying to do is predict
the longevity of the relationship okay
so here's the data if it falls under
five positive interactions - one
negative interaction the relationship
continue fair enough too much negative
that's easy to understand if it exceeds
11 positive to one negative the
relationship doesn't last
why no challenge right what do you want
from your partner bliss no no no you
don't you want periods of peace
punctuated by a good fight and that
because that means you respect them
means you have something to offer each
other and it means that you're both
growing and so you don't want the fight
to be too dramatic because well then you
retreat you can't settle it but the
person that you can completely map and
who only does positive things for you
it's like a you don't know that person B
they're not communicating with you nor
you with them maybe they're just
subordinating themselves to you or you
to them and you're not growing you want
someone who can it's a real relationship
is a wrestling match it's a grappling
it's a grappling phenomena that you both
emerge transformed from and that's what
people want you don't want to push over
not not unless there's something wrong
with them now a narcissistic person who
never wants to be challenged will want a
partner who does nothing but deliver
exactly what they're told to deliver but
they will mistreat them beyond belief
and perhaps deservedly so